Lego Star Wars The Force awakens I
genuinely had no interest in reviewing
this game in fact I barely had an
interest in playing it and then I heard
little whispers like hey maybe check out
that game you know you might actually
enjoy it because I'm a huge Star Wars
fan I'm a big Lego fan I have no idea
why I had no interest in playing it
probably because they're all the same
most Lego games are pretty much all the
same there's good humor you run around
you collect LEGO pieces what could you
do as soon as I sat down and start
playing this game I could barely put it
down this is a terrific game and a ton
of fun so I would love to actually talk
about some of the things I really enjoy
about this game as well as compare it to
another Star Wars game that's come out
recently so if you never played a Lego
game before essentially what they are is
a very humorous take on something like
the Jurassic world game last year was a
lot of fun they try to follow the
general storyline of the film's that
this game is about so this one's force
awakens so yes it's gonna follow the
plot of the movie but they also
interject a lot of humor there's a lot
of good jokes what I loved about this
game is how simplistically fun it was do
you guys remember when games were just
fun when they weren't overly concerned
about DLC ripping the money out of our
wallets to the point where we couldn't
afford anything else except to play this
game that maybe wasn't even all that
good yeah I'm talking to you Star Wars
Battlefront that game was disappointing
as hell the DLC for that game was so
expensive and the single-player campaign
took me like 45 minutes to beat I waited
in line at midnight for battlefront I
was so pissed what that game I did a
review for that that's another video
what I loved about this game is that
it's a completed game it's also massive
I beat the main story of this game I got
the end credits and everything and I was
only 21% through the things that I could
accomplish in this game when you beat
this game you can play under free mode
and go under characters that you've
unlocked already to planets all over the
galaxy there's an absurdum
of things to do which is so awesome when
you have a really fun game like this
it's also really funny it pokes fun at
Star Wars in all the right ways there's
a lot of really good humor you'll be
passing by stormtroopers and they're
having weird conversations one of the
funniest ones was where they were
talking about how they scored a three
out of ten on target practice and the
trooper was like whoa that's a troop
record there's all these amazing
sequences that play off of the force
awakens like in the movie when rey takes
control of the one trooper you get to
lead this trooper around in this game
and command him to do various things but
he's like this zombie trooper just
running around and he's sort of in love
with you and thinks you're like the best
and wants to do everything for you it's
so so funny there were two things about
this game though that really really
surprised me one of the biggest ones
were the flying missions when you get a
fly around as the x-wing or as the
Millennium Falcon that was awesome
way better than the flying stuff in
battlefront it blew me away it was so
much fun
and it's not just because of the novelty
of flying around and star warships with
Star Wars music playing because I've
played a ton of Star Wars flying games
all the way from Rogue Squadron to rogue
leader battle for Naboo Starfighter
there's tons of Star Wars flying games
what makes this one fun is that they
actually get the flying right the
controls were innovative and intuitive
to feeling like you were actually
controlling these ships it's tons and
tons of fun and that's something I
really want to reiterate this game was
fun there was never a moment in my
entire runtime of the main game that I
felt frustrated I miss when games were
more simplistic like this where games
weren't so concerned about some new
innovation and technology we have to do
virtual reality you have to do motion
controls we have to do this we have to
do that no let's just have a fun game
and entertain the gamer and that's what
this game did so well now the second
thing that really surprised me is that
this actually has the entire main voice
cast of force awakens including Harrison
Ford and Daisy Ridley and John boyega
and Anthony Daniels and all these guys
they take little bits of dialogue that's
actually from force awakens just like
the Lego Jurassic world game did but
they also provide new dialogue I was
just like not expecting Harrison Ford to
actually do new dialogue as han Solo
that was one of the big surprise
besides I can't even picture him doing
voice work for a video game but he did
now as you can see behind me I bought
the Wii U version of this game and a lot
of people had complained about glitches
on the Wii U version especially on the
Amazon reviews now I encountered one
glitch and I think Nintendo has already
released a patch for some of these
things
there was one portion of the game where
the sound got really weird for like 30
seconds the sound and the music just got
really wobbly and then it just went away
I never had a problem again if I'm being
blunt and completely honest this is the
best Star Wars game I've played in years
and easily the most fun that I have had
with the Lego games I'm gonna give Lego
Star Wars The Force awakens a 9 out of
10 as I said I had absolutely no plans
to review this game but it surprised the
hell out of me and I found myself
wanting to talk about it guys thank you
so much as always for watching I'll try
to do more video game reviews it's hard
because there's so much longer and they
take more time but I'll try to give you
guys some more of those in the future
you guys are the best thanks again for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck monetized
can I also just say that it comes with
an instruction booklet
you don't realize game companies just
how much this little thing means to some
of us collectors